do you ever communicate with any of the
other ladies no um i respect everyone's
you know space at some point we will
we'll we'll have to at some point um
and i think that we're all grown and i
think that everyone has love and respect
and i think it'll be fine we just don't
necessarily need to at the moment
how are you feeling i'm feeling great
yeah excited i'm so excited nervous of
course yeah i'm a whole human i'm
responsible for
yeah yeah you grew up with
strong women very much so um my mom my
grandma very independent um they all had
their own careers so i think it really
changed kind of how i viewed
relationships
which lisa that's why this is a unique
relationship but it seems like you are
navigating it well i think i'm
navigating it well because it's just
naturally effortless like we just get
along so well and everything just flows
and when you have honesty and all those
things it kind of makes it easy and i
think our communication is so great that
if there's something i don't like or
something i want to talk about or
address like he's very easy so
somebody i literally she just walked up
when i parked she walked up and said
look at this something somebody sent you
in the mail and i
i'm a huge fan of nick's i mean he's one
of my favorite people known since he's
been little and
i said on the show he has committed the
fatherhood and this person
wrote me a note about how wrong i was
for saying that he was committed to
fatherhood how would you say
to answer that person who wrote this
note is like how dare you say that
because that has nothing to do with
fatherhood him having all these children
what would you say to that person you
know i feel like that's probably
the thing that's brought up the most and
people you know try to paint him in such
a different light than he is he has the
ability to be wherever he wants whenever
he wants he makes his schedule he can if
i need him on tour he can get on a plane
and come home whether you're commercial
or not he has the resources to be
present and available and majority of
families don't have that so you work
here nine to five let's say and you know
you get home the kids are already asleep
and then on the weekends like it's just
not the same presence he gets to be
fully present when he's here and dictate
that time and manage that so
i just find it so interesting that
people think that the typical
way of raising a household is the only
way i feel like one day there could be a
show called the cannons or something
like that
could there maybe maybe i don't know
it depends
do you ever communicate with any of the
other ladies no um i respect everyone's
you know space at some point we will
we'll we'll have to at some point
and i think that we're all grown and i
think that everyone has love and respect
and i think it'll be fine we just don't
necessarily need to at the moment i
think no matter what the kids are going
to be super close and supported and it's
very easy they can all communicate you
know after a certain time kind of step
out
um but i'm kind of for what everyone
wants like i don't want to press like oh
we all have to do thanksgiving we all
have to do whatever
i just want to make it easy on him and
on the kids and just let them know their
siblings and choose what they want you
know one always makes you want to have
two i know
i heard
right i'm just telling we'll see you get
to a point you're like oh i want to do
this again yeah this is the greatest
thing ever i mean we'll see how do you
split time or how often will he be able
to come see his son i mean that all
obviously dictates what's going on in
his work schedule um but he's great
even you know yesterday saw had a
sensory class in the morning with some
kids and then has you know the twins the
next couple hours for the park like he
makes the schedule work um we all can go
through the assistant to make sure it's
on the calendar if there's something
important um
but anything you say you need from him
this man always shows up so you know we
have x y and z it's on the calendar he's
there his poor assistant keeps it going
it
manages everything everything i don't
know how she does it
wow yeah i don't know how either of them
do it right right i mean just the
birthdays the names yeah that's a lot
that's a lot it's a lot he makes it
happen though
nobody can say he can't show up he does
he is one of the five busiest people in
in the world is um he on the clock right
now so when you probably when you call
is he gonna just break he's coming he's
definitely ready because any minute we
could be having this baby so he knows
he's on call um but he's also on tour so
he's on tour right now how will he get
here in time where are you as soon as
your water breaks you're like bruh
basically because this could happen any
moment now i mean it could happen during
this interview
basically yeah we were hoping to make
news we're like we're already home so
so tell me about the delivery will nick
be here yes nick will absolutely be here
he has no choice
okay so he will definitely be here yes
he will be here of course he wants to be
here so we have a birth team that'll
come to the house and my family will be
here and he'll be here so it'll be very
intimate and different so it'll be your
family like a little tub yeah basically
and and
nick and yeah so my family will stay
down here we won't subject them to that
but i do have the bathtub obviously in
the house upstairs and the tub that they
bring so you can kind of go between so
it'll be the water birth you can pick
either one
when you're laboring and whatever's more
comfortable when did you start getting
the nursery and what's the style that
you were going what were you going for
because this is a boy yeah so i think
that was kind of the hard thing for me i
wanted really elevated and luxury not
like too typical baby nursery but i
wanted to keep it super neutral um and
not take away the masculinity of it so
it was kind of an interesting
the thing to gauge all right do you have
a name i do you do how did you come up
with an a
um we were actually struggling because
you know he likes
very he likes to be very different
differently and
i
not so much so we went back and forth
for a while and i had come up with one
name and he jazzed it up a little bit
and then we finally picked it was but we
knew that was it and we stuck with it
after that now this is what's
interesting you two have dated for a
long long people don't know that you've
dated for a long time no and he has let
you
go
explain that so i think that's probably
the most interesting part is that
at
any moment that i say i'm unhappy or i'm
not getting my needs met or maybe you
know what maybe this isn't for me i did
reconsider it at some point and i did
get married and then i knew that really
wasn't for me he allows me to have my
own growth and be my own person to
figure out what really made me happy in
order for us to get to the step to
actually welcome a child because this
was conversation we had for a long time
um on and off and i was
unsure and he was like you need to
figure that out first and once i did
here we are
what was his reaction when you told me
you were pregnant he was excited he was
happy i mean we it wasn't you know an
accident or anything like we were that's
what i was going to say yeah
you've been dating for a long time so
you guys said let's have a baby yeah and
you talked about this on a podcast you
recently did that some people gave you
grief about that announcement how hard
was that
well i think that's the other thing it
wasn't really an announcement it was
meant to be a very private intimate
family setting
and we're not really sure how it got out
because we only had about 20 people
there and majority was family and my
best friends that would never you know
tell anyone
so i think having
us be exploited in the sense of like not
being able to come out on our own timing
and constructively the way we wanted to
because we wanted to be respectful of
what was going on um
that was really hard because that was
not ideal and our plan was actually to
keep this private until it was
it wasn't such a sensitive time
and obviously we couldn't do anything
about the circumstances and what
happened and it's really unfortunate and
like my heart goes out to her so that
was the last thing i wanted to do
um was hit her while she was down and
him you know they're both grieving so it
was a really it was really hard because
you also want to like celebrate your
child in this new life and you know the
relationship that you've carried for so
long
so it was it was tough
you said also on your podcast that you
love nick and you could you ever see you
two being together permanently i mean i
plan on being together permanently no
matter what whether it's you know for us
it's like also a spiritual thing and a
mental connection so even if we weren't
physically we will always be together we
will always maintain our relationship i
can't ever see us not getting along
honestly
um we're cutting that
relationship that we have not now but
eventually you're a young and beautiful
woman will you date again and or will
you are you guys will
see each other mutually or will you well
see
whatever you want to do whatever yeah i
mean at the end of the day i love our
relationship um and obviously my
family's number one to me and we'll make
that work and i'm happy
so if at any point that changes we have
our respect and we'll figure that out by
the way who you are also real estate
mogul you're flipping you're doing a lot
of real estate stuff right what kind of
how busy is your business schedule and
how you're handling that yeah so that's
that's been the biggest thing i think
for me is i don't want to step away from
business but i also know that i really
want to spend time with my son and how
important it is the next couple of years
so obviously i haven't encountered it
just yet but i am planning to take a
little bit of time off um or i was i was
doing three months to six months off and
then i ended up getting a really amazing
opportunity which i can't share just yet
but
i will be going back to work a lot
sooner than i anticipated
[Music]